hello everyone welcome back to the
channel we are celebrating another film
on the festival run right now it's the
movie stay awake jamie wyatt finn
congratulations
i'm so so happy for you i have to send
an extra special like congratulations
and i'm so happy to jamie because for
anyone who doesn't know we went to
school together and
to be able to see someone who you
thought was super cool in school go on
to make a a great feature like this it's
really like something else i'm so proud
of you and so happy for you
thanks so it's so it's so cool to be
here with with all y'all and i i love
your show perry it's kind of surreal
getting to be on it so
all right let's get into it so jamie i'm
sure you've done this quite a bit along
the way but with a festival movie a lot
of our viewers will not know what stay
awake is about just yet so will you do
the honors and give everyone a synopsis
yeah sure um stay awake is uh it kind of
comes from a lot of my personal
experiences uh growing up as a teen uh
it's basically about uh
two brothers who are trying to help
their mom uh through a prescription drug
addiction that she has in small town
america um
and you know i guess the only other
thing i would say is i just remember
growing up a lot and um always seeing
films about addiction
um and never never really seeing films
about the family members of addicts and
sort of the roller coaster ride they
have to go on um and so when when i was
fortunate enough to be in a position
where i could where i could
um write something about it uh that's
sort of the angle i wanted to take and
luckily i had some incredible actors uh
who i got to collaborate with and uh
yeah i'm really really proud of how it
turned out all right so bringing school
back into the mix briefly because i know
we got a lot of viewers out there who
are you know trying to become filmmakers
some of them are in school so what would
you say was the key to bridging the gap
between being in a program like that and
actually getting the green light for
your first feature film or first feature
film uh you have a documentary as well
but this is your first feature that
you're directing solo
yeah yeah in my first narrative film as
well first fiction one um
you know i think the bridge it was um
honestly just staying perseverant
through it it it it just took it took a
long you know it takes a long time i
remember people telling me oh it's going
to take you four years and you know
between school that's the average i was
like i don't even know what that means
uh and it took it took this film beyond
that average but um
you know i
i'm really happy
that it took that long as i also had a
chance to rewrite the story a lot i had
a chance to meet a lot of great people
that ended up kind of becoming this
family so i think just getting into
places where you can find a lot of great
collaborators um and then just staying
really passionate and persevering about
your your project is sort of i think
what got to stay awake there four years
is such a specific and random number i'm
trying to like piece together what that
might be it might have taken stay awake
a little bit longer than that uh but
four years it was i remember back back
then i stopped in like four years why
because we had made a short on the same
uh
subject but it just the amount of pieces
you know the stars that have to align
uh you know whether it be the actors you
want to work with uh the budget
obviously the location
uh there's the pandemic that we had to
contend with you know a lot of pieces
are sort of a part of all of it
all right finn and wyatt climbed make
jamie blush a little bit so again his
his first uh narrative feature right
here you guys have a lot of
opportunities at your fingertips right
now so when you get a project like this
that comes your way what is it about
your very first meetings with jamie that
make you think like yup i know he can do
this and this is a new director that i
need to spend time with and work with
i love to script immediately so i was
already like
80 percent sold but of course a director
has a huge impact on what the project is
going to turn into
knowing that he was the writer and
director i already know that there's
like synergy in the vision and
after talking to jay i don't even know
we didn't even spend much time talking
about the film i mean of course we did
but
a majority of our conversation was about
music and just getting to know each
other and i was like i really connect
with this with this person on a
friendship level and also a creative
level we shared a lot of the same
interests and i just after seeing his
his short uh the stay awake short i felt
confident in his ability to turn out his
vision and i
am so glad that i got to be a part of it
i love you jamie i love you man
thank you
yeah i mean
i read the script and hopped on a call
with jamie i love the script by the way
i'm not just skipping over that um i
hopped on a call with jamie
and our call was pretty similar to that
i mean we just talked about a bunch of
random stuff and and getting to know
jamie in just every way possible was
like so
nice and and authentic like it didn't
feel like he was just trying to get to
know me for his project it felt like he
was trying to get to know me as a person
because he was because jamie's such a
genuine sweet guy
and
i think another thing that was really
big for me was like
and this this happened more specifically
on set but also in that um original call
any question i would ask jamie about
this script about this movie about
experience he would be able to answer
like almost immediately
he is so passionate about what he does
and he has put every ounce of his being
into this project and that's something i
respect endlessly
and for him to go out of his way and say
yeah i would like you to be a part of
this
i i can't say no to that you know
you could feel what you're describing
when you actually watch the movie
there's like an extreme amount of
sincerity i think from the direction but
also from every single person involved
and you know i don't know this for sure
but i watch the movie and it gives me
the sense that every single person you
had involved is giving hundred percent
and cares about the story to their core
and that makes all the difference on
movies like this
yeah you you i think you said it
perfectly perry it we're really lucky to
be able to work with people who would
take what you sort of brought into it
and they
they took that from you and they moved
it forward in in directions where they
took ownership um
you know the the the actors a lot of the
cast the crew the the location managers
i mean who you know endlessly
tried to just find the best locations it
was really there's so many different
components uh to a film like this that's
you know like kind of a labor of love
for everyone um i i really lucked out
many questions many follow-up questions
what you just brought up there but first
going back to the uh the writing phase
here so you kind of brought this up
before it does feel
it feels like we pretty often see very
you know like black and white depictions
of of addiction and how one should deal
with them but this right here is a
pretty complex exploration of you know i
guess i would say finding a balance
between supporting a loved one but also
not at the expense of one's own
well-being so can you kind of talk us
through a little bit about finding out
the right balance for those two things
in this script
yeah i mean
you know a lot of it honestly was just
drawing from
a lot of the personal experiences that i
had and that people um who are also in
the treatment community
uh had that i know um in just sort of
expressing that patience
mixed with that frustration mixed with
um
the question of always sort of asking
like how much of myself do i put into
trying to help someone that i love
uh manage manage a very difficult
disease
um you know how how much
uh do i owe to myself to step away in in
um
you know
develop a sense of self-care for for you
and
maybe your brother your sibling other
people it's it's really tough uh i i
really wanted to sort of
illustrate that as best i could as best
as a film can
um just sort of the ups and the downs of
of that of that journey
it was very beautifully done
all right finn and wyatt for you too i
was wondering what kind of uh backstory
work you did here and maybe what kind of
conversations you had with jamie early
on specifically to figure out why ethan
and derek have such different feelings
and approaches to dealing with this
situation at the onset
um there were a lot of conversations
about that obviously and
and i remember some of the ones at the
beginning were
i feel like they were more simple
questions and as we got deeper as we got
into some of the more complex scenes i
feel like as we grew with these
characters we kind of were able to
understand their perspectives and and
jamie was so willing to be open about
his experience which helped i know me
and uh finn as well like really
understand um what these characters are
going through and
and i think the difference in their
perspectives
i remember
asking jamie about that and
correct me if i'm wrong i believe the
answer was kind of about like the amount
of time spent with her before she kind
of fell into this
um
you know and into
her addiction and when she i'm sorry um
when she was more of just
that loving caring mother that that
derek is so
like
set on you know like he is so
he holds out so much hope for her and in
a way that makes him kind of
almost like the nicer one but like
ethan just hasn't hadn't spent that much
time with her like there's a part in the
movie when they were talking about like
a memory and and nathan's like i don't
remember that
about like her just having like that mom
moment and he just doesn't remember and
i think that kind of explains
why their
their outlooks on on taking care of her
so different is because just like
yeah that amount of time i don't know if
that made a lot of sense that sorry do
you mind me asking um what were some of
those more complex scenes that might
have been more challenging to explore
um a big one was all the the scene that
we're talking about the memory in um
when we're at dinner when i go to visit
her when when uh derek's gone and
we just kind of had this really
beautiful conversation and first of all
that was such a fun scene to film i mean
not fun it was fun it was just nice like
acting
opposite chrissy matt's is like i mean
she's amazing she's incredible so so
being able to work with her and also
like this finn guy he's pretty cool like
i don't want to sell him short at all
he's amazing and i love him so much
but
um yeah i i just that that scene was
that scene was
there's a lot going on in that scene
there's a lot of subtext going on in
between like
i remember there's a there's a point in
it where it's like
can i love her like or can i like treat
her like my mom like she's like acting
like my mom right now like she's giving
me relationship advice she's being so
kind and she's being like
there for me she's like
and
and and i asked jamie i'm like is there
like a piece of hope in that like will
he be hopeful from here on out which i
think
i think ethan is very careful with with
um
the moments he chooses to be vulnerable
and trust people and i think that scene
kind of highlights that and him like
finally being able to open up to her i
think was it was a big scene and
jamie guided me like beautifully through
it so
just to
like piggyback off of that i love that
scene and i love the subtext that you're
referring to there's like specifically a
storyline
uh within ethan's character that is you
know it is very subtextual but the way
that they connect there's this moment
where you see them
like transcend what they're actually
speaking
and have this moment of love and
connection that is like
i'm i might mess up i'm your mom
[Music]
and i'm always going to be here for you
no matter what even if it doesn't look
like it even if i'm not well enough to
physically be there i always want to and
i always love you and that that's a
scene for me like i've choked up i've
watched the movie a handful of times now
and and i always joke i just love
watching their dynamic
how about uh a habit for you in terms of
was there any particular day on the
shooting schedule that you know i don't
know you circled in red and say that day
that scene in particular i'm gonna have
my work cut out for me the most um i
mean there's a lot
of emotion uh sprinkled throughout this
film
so
uh there was a handful of days but i
think the one that sticks out for me
when i'm thinking back on it is there's
a scene towards the end of the movie
where ethan and derek are once again
searching for their mother
and it ends in a point where again i
don't know if we're spoiling things but
it ends in a point where it's it's a
pretty harrowing experience for both of
them and you sort of see derek break
you know there's this this positivity in
this pep that derek is always
carrying on on his shoulder
um
and
you see all of that just crumbled
beneath him like the foundation breaks
and
and so that moment you know i wouldn't
say i was like nervous for but i just
knew it'd be difficult to go there
especially having known jamie's story
and being able to relate to it in a lot
of ways
it's it's scary you know even as an
actor knowing that you're playing a role
and it's fiction
sometimes you go to those emotional
places and it's it's hard to get out of
but
that was one thing that i loved about
this set so much as there was so much
support and encouragement
and
jamie was like this
protector of of us as actors which is
something i deeply appreciate and you
don't always experience so those
sensitive subjects and those highly
emotional scenes
i always felt
like it was a safe environment to
explore those things and
really become raw and vulnerable for for
the film and for the purpose of
storytelling i always feel like that is
well worth highlighting to the max here
so jamie as you know like the leader you
know everything trickles down from the
top what are certain things that you set
out to do as a director on set to make
sure that i mean not even just your cast
who are going to these challenging
places but even just like your crew and
every single person that you're making
this story with to make sure everyone
feels you know like safe supported and
like their voice is being heard
that's a great question i mean i i think
that role is especially important on a
film like this because
again no one's you know no one's getting
paid millions of dollars to on these on
these indie films it's you're really
there uh
you know for a reason um and
i think
these sorts of films to me not that i've
had a chance to make millions of movies
but i you really get to do the the
collaborative aspect of of filmmaking of
art is sort of what you get to hone in
on here and that's what i try to do you
know you try to you try to bring people
in to
um
into the film as best you can you know i
i think a lot of
not that i'm like you know a super
experienced director but what i found
was a lot of what my role was was sort
of
trying to bring out the best in people
and that happens in a bunch of different
ways some people want to be heard some
people just want to be left alone
some people um
want um
you know have a lot of opinions
beautiful opinions that um
you know if if you really
give them
free reign they come back um knowing
what your intent was and they just shock
you i mean that's my favorite part of
these processes is when you have an idea
you have a blueprint and then you get to
surround yourself with people that are
you know in their specific areas much
smarter than you and they come back with
something that just astonishes you and
then as a whole collectively you come up
with something that's a lot better than
you could have ever done yourself and so
i you know i i think that comes in a
bunch of different ways it was my
favorite part honestly of making this
film and i hope to be able to do it
again because it's it really is
beautiful it's a beautiful experience
getting to make art with people all
right speaking about different
approaches to the work uh wyatt and finn
a two-parter for you here
you hit set you're working together what
is something about both of your
processes that align that the second you
hit set that particular thing was in
sync but then can you each share
something that the other did that you
know wasn't like how you work and was
maybe refreshing for you that's a great
question actually
your questions are so good
i want to say like
uh
i don't know if this answers your
question specifically but um
for a lot of the shoot i was scared for
the scenes where i'm crying because i
just like have had trouble with that
recently i'm just kind of getting those
emotions out but there's something
something about finn that brought that
out of me and
i feel like emotionally we were always
on the same level like in every scene we
were
there and it was so easy to connect with
him and to
just like be there with him it was so
easy to be present um and i don't i
don't know if that answers the question
specifically but
i i feel that um
you know our processes were a little
different and just like how we'd uh
how we memorize lines like i don't know
we we just like
i sort of i do this thing where i'll
memorize every scene
prior to shooting something which
usually like scenes change but it just
helps me to like have this almost uh
muscle memory of of a film so no matter
where we pick up and shooting
um i'm not sure if that's different your
process but
it was just it was cool to
be able to see you
i think i think the reason i say that is
because i approach scenes and acting
very sporadically like i i do a bunch of
character prep and like journal out the
hobbies of the character
and stuff like that so then when i'm
filming
i
like
hop in and i i don't
i don't know if i like
do a bunch of like prep the day of i'm
just like okay i've done all the work
and i'm just like
um and it was really cool to see like
why it uh
take take time and i i've taken some
inspiration from him like on the day to
really center himself and get into uh
like the right emotional head space for
a scene uh because there were these
times where we had these highly
emotional scenes together where i just
be like reading my book like la da da
and you know just like sort of in a
different head space and then i see
wyatt like ridding his sides and like in
the corner like this and i'm like okay
wait there's there's something going on
there so i really appreciated that about
about why it is like he's really good
about uh remaining present and uh you
know taking the time to hone in uh on
emotional moments
i love that
all right we obviously have to bring up
chrissy here who's a very big part of
this movie uh i'll toss this one to you
jamie so i've got to imagine when she
gets involved it's a big deal and like
especially as an ep her involvement
probably adds a lot of momentum to the
project so what were your first
conversations with her like and how does
an offer to star in a movie evolve into
her also getting involved in the
producerial capacity
sure um well you know
it it's i i can't stress enough just how
lucky
i i really have been
all three of these actors that i got to
primarily work with just how um
sweet and vulnerable
really all of them are in terms of what
they bring to a story uh
and you know chrissy's definitely no
exception she was kind enough to to meet
with me physically actually on the last
day before kovit it was literally it was
the um we met at a restaurant
and it was a ghost town and we were both
a little we were like wow it looks like
this pandemic thing's really really
starting to take shape it was it was in
february or march it was in march and
then every the whole world went into
lockdown so it was it was actually
literally the last meal i had at a
restaurant was with her
and um
it's a lot of what uh
finn and wyatt were saying you know it's
a lot of just getting to know the other
person
yeah
getting to see if you know you can you
can collaborate with them if it
literally if you kind of
share a similar
world view about uh how to make how to
make art and film
um
we had the same birthday which was kind
of fun like there were a lot of weird
things that lined up really nicely
between she and i
um and then and then covet happened and
in terms of sort of taking a step
further from your question
you know once
everybody came on
obviously the way actors come on in
financing and production and schedules
at all it's all interconnected
and um
if people fall out that affects
everything too
and
you know when when the pandemic happened
chrissy always said you know i'll stay
on
and
in this world in the limited experience
i have you just never know with people
like you know a lot of the times people
will say that and then a bigger project
will come uh and you know for stay awake
that it's like literally any project
we're like a small indie film and and
you know so it's it's
i didn't know what to expect um and this
project meant a lot to me i spent a lot
of time it's literally based off a lot
of important struggles i've had and a
lot of people have
um
and so
you know
she stayed on she really is a person of
her word and i can't uh i can't say i'm
surprised uh having gotten to know her
better now but uh she's she's really
just such an amazing human being um and
she took the ep role seriously like
she'd hate that i'd bring this up but i
remember
there were times on like a hot friday in
the middle of the summer and suddenly
like ice cream sandwiches would appear
for the entire crew and like nobody you
know whoever donated them was supposed
to be anonymous but like everyone
obviously knew it was chrissy and like
she would just do little things like
that in addition to taking her role and
her character very seriously and really
getting 110
she would do a lot of things to help
inspire the cast and the crew because
it's what you said perry i mean it
really it's a trickle-down thing and
i've definitely been in experiences with
the main actors of a of a film
where it just it just takes one person
to really just create a you know a
toxicity that can kind of permeate and i
just she and finn and wyatt really set
the tone that ripples with a lot of
other people um in just creating this
familial
kind of uh beautiful setup that was that
felt like summer camp uh you know in the
catskills and you you need that kind of
environment to be able to tackle the
immense challenges that come with making
a smaller production like this so all
three of you feel free to jump in on
this but can you give me an example of a
day when things like we're not going to
plan at all but you were able to pivot
or find a creative solution and a scene
was better off because of it
everything went perfectly
[Laughter]
i i mean nothing comes to mind for me i
i don't know jamie
we changed some locations at the very
end um that ended up i think making the
film a lot stronger like initially uh
derek was gonna work at a gas station
uh and i always wanted ethan to work but
couldn't find a good place for him uh
and then we just found this beaut just
incredible bowling alley an incredible
ice cream shop and
uh both of them had constraints to them
but i think a lot of the times those
constraints really helped us focus and
edit it was at a time in the production
it was a 21-day shoot where i think we
were all the actors the crew everybody
was sort of coming together nicely and
we were really able to i think
make make something really strong for
those i'm really proud of those those
locations i don't remember i don't
remember that i was just gonna say
um
my mom is in the movie
because
this this is my last part that was my
last project before i turned 18. so she
kind of had to be with me and
um she was on set for the bowling and
while they were doing the montage when
i'm bowling um
she's in the background
and i just
i did not yeah she's in like the green
outfit i just uh
it makes me really happy that jamie
included that so thank you
that's like the kind of thing that goes
in the movies imdb trivia section
actually here's a very random question
for all three of you i ask this all the
time on my interview series collider
ladies night but i'll pose it to the
three of you because i did look at your
imdb trivia sections and they're either
non-existent or they're very very mature
so i want each of you to tell me a very
random fact about yourself that should
go on that page
um okay just a fun fact about me
uh
one time i was staying at the
nickelodeon hotel
and they were having this game show that
you could sign up for and you had to
list like a special talent
and
so i decided and i'd never tried it
before but i decided that my special
talent was going to be that i could pick
things up with my shoulder blades and so
i figured out how to do that and yes i
am a freak yes i did get asked to join
the nickelodeon hotel game show
and that is actually the peak of my
career
does this hotel still exist and can i go
i have no idea i was like eight
but that's there's some really deep cut
trivia for you
okay that's a good one can you guys top
that now
i was a winner of beetlefest
like two decades ago
um back when it was around that would be
a i'm a massive beatles fan
so that could be uh
beetle fest
it's a it's a it's it we would have to
do three more of these interviews perry
to really get into the minutia of it but
it's uh
it one day one day but uh there is that
i also have a really yeah that's
i'll stop there
i'm just imagining like a convention
with a bunch of people out of pet
beetles which i know that's not what
you're talking about i think that's what
i heard right out of the gate and then i
realized super visual though
all right you're not you're not getting
lit up here what you got i'll just uh i
know how to solve a five by five rubik's
cube and i and i enjoyed doing it a lot
that's not that that second part you
didn't need but i that first part is the
trivia i do have a good one that should
be on our imdb trivia that i totally
forgot about that uh
was one of the weirder nights of the
film do you remember the car accident
well we that was an actual car you know
cars crashing and they there was all of
these logistics that happened with
having to get a car and there has to be
two cars that look the same
you know obviously you can't crash the
car
that we shot in etc
the the production crew like jumped
through all these hoops to make it all
happen and we got there that night it
was a long shooting night we had all a
lot of these car scenes back to back
back all the sing-alongs etc the first
the first scene of the night was the car
crash itself
and the car drove there and as soon as
it got there it wouldn't start
uh
it just it just didn't start so
like every everybody like the whole crew
wanted to come and witness this car this
car accident and
the car literally just didn't start
anymore as soon as it got there it
stopped
and uh we literally had to get another
car to push the car
to make it look like it was it was going
and and then i i think we pulled it off
pretty well but that was something that
i remember everybody was just like
could not believe i
you all remember that like that was that
was crazy it was very funny to watch
there's just like this huge truck that
launched the car straight into a car
accident like what
i'm always impressed by vfx and all that
type of stuff but that right there is
true movie magic
oh yeah it was
slingshotted a car basically using
another car
all right i gotta let you guys go you
got some celebrating to do you are the
opening night opening night film of the
san francisco international film
festival so huge congratulations on that
and i can't wait to see where stay awake
goes from here everybody out there keep
an eye out for it thanks again for your
time today guys cheers thank you thanks
perry it's great to see you